como ya lo estaba adelantando llegamos a
hablar de los deportes juano y por
supuesto no con un tema pues tan ameno
porque todo este conflicto con acnur
también tiene repercusiones en el
deporte y le pregunto las reacciones que
hay a la intervención de rusia en
ucrania juan pero raúl que las sabe
porque el deporte no es ajeno a un
conflicto de esta magnitud y una de las
principales consecuencias de esta
intervención rusa es que ucrania
suspendió la renovación de la liga de
fútbol la primer league de ucrania que
estaba previsto comenzará este viernes
hacia la nación el propio campeonato
explicando que esto es consecuencias de
la ley marcial que empezó a regir en
esta nación como parte del ataque ruso y
en todo este contexto de fútbol o de
fútbol vamos a hablar de dos reacciones
que llegan desde este deporte la primera
entrada de fedor smolov jugador de la
selección de rusia quien ha llegado a
ser capitán de este equipo y quien hizo
parte de los convocados para el mundial
de rusia 2018 no a la guerra compartió
en su cuenta de instagram junto con ese
molde que vemos de un corazón roto y la
bandera de ucrania hablando precisamente
de la parte ucraniana se pronunció una
gran voz que seguramente muchos de
ustedes conocen no es otro que andrei
shevchenko esto es un comunicado del
miércoles en la previa al bombardeo dice
search en como ucrania es mi patria
siempre he estado orgulloso de mi pueblo
y de mi país hemos pasado por muchos
momentos difíciles y durante los últimos
30 años nos hemos formado como nación
una nación sincera trabajadora con
ciudadanos que aman la libertad ese es
nuestro activo más importante dice
hitchin con uno de los mejores
delanteros sin duda alguna que ha habido
en la última en este último siglo
goleador con el milan campeón de la
champions league también fue entrenador
de la selección ucraniana en la pasada
eurocopa y también con una incursión en
la política quiso ser parlamentario de
el país de eugenia juan y seguimos con
fútbol porque hay un asunto clave en el
fútbol europeo porque la final de este
año precisamente de la champions league
es en rusia así es es una coincidencia
que llegará en ese momento la uefa tiene
previsto celebrar la final de la
champions de esta temporada el 28 de
mañana san petersburgo pero desde esta
semana ha sido precisamente el premier
británico por el johnson quien ha
liderado un rechazo frente a que hacía
rusia quien acoja esta gran cita hoy
jueves la uefa convocó para mañana una
reunión extraordinaria para dicen y
evaluar la situación en torno a esta
intervención en rusia de rusia en
ucrania dicen que van a tomar todas las
decisiones necesarias se trata de una
final que juez se jugaría en teoría en
el gastro arena un importante un
imponente estadio que estábamos viendo y
que fue sede también en la pasada
eurocopa y también en el pasado mundial
de rusia 2018 esta es una cuestión que
preocupa mucho porque la final de la
champions hay uno de los principales
eventos deportivos del año y que sea en
este contexto en san petersburgo tendría
unas consecuencias mediáticamente muy
importantes vamos a ver entonces qué va
a pasar juan porque todo está también
sobre en la mesa y también esta
situación amenaza con afectar las
eliminatorias a qatar 2022 eventos muy
importantes en el fútbol mundial es que
como decíamos el deporte no puede ser
ajeno a toda esta situación hay dudas
sobre qué va a pasar con las
eliminatorias el mundial por los
partidos que tienen previsto jugar tanto
rusia como ucrania polonia por ejemplo
ya expresó su preocupación ante la fija
por la paz ante la fifa por la visita
que tiene previsto hacer a moscú para la
repesca la copa mundo de qatar 2020 es
un encuentro que si jugará o está
previsto que se juegue en moscú el 24 de
marzo y es una semifinal a partido único
dentro del nuevo formato que tiene la
uefa para las eliminatorias su cráneo
por su parte visita a escocia en glasgow
el mismo día muchas dudas en torno a
estos partidos en medio de un calendario
que ya de por sí se muestra muy muy
ajustado con todos los aplazamientos un
calendario que está muy cargado para los
futbolistas así que un aplazamiento de
esos partidos se mostraría como algo muy
complicado y es algo que está ya a la
vuelta de la esquina el 24 de marzo
también hay dudas en el baloncesto hay
tres equipos rusos que están jugando
ahora mismo la euroliga el semi del
física de moscú y el unics kazan de
hecho el barcelona viaja a rusia en
teoría tiene previsto para viajar hoy
porque juegan mañana en san petersburgo
con 3 zenit y el domingo en moscú la
euroliga les acaba de garantizar que van
a tener seguridad para entrar y salir
del país pero ya jugadores de barcelona
que están explicando expresando dudas
vamos a viajar a rusia en este momento
para jugar dos partidos de euroliga es
una situación un poco extraña
seguramente que se va a seguir
desarrollando conforme la euroliga
avanza y conforme avanza la situación y
juán totalmente entendible pues la
preocupación de los jugadores no es para
menos pero también hay voces en el mundo
del tiene juan si una voz su muy
importante un vídeo que compartió en
esta gran la tenista elina svitolina una
de las mejores raquetas del circuito
femenino ya re difundió un vídeo en el
que se pide no a la guerra en ucrania
svitolina acompañó este vídeo que vemos
que son imágenes de ucrania con un
mensaje en el que dice estar orgullosa
de ser ucraniana y pide unidad en ese
mensaje están llegando muchas reacciones
ra volvamos a pasar a la fórmula 1
porque sebastian vettel el piloto alemán
de la escudería aston martin se
pronunció en medio de las pruebas que se
están realizando de pretemporada en
barcelona que él no va a ir a disfrutar
el gran premio de rusia que está
disputado que se corra el 25 de
septiembre en sochi dice sebastian
vettel está muriendo gente por razones
estúpidas no creo que haya ir al gran
premio de rusia yo no iré un
posicionalmente fuera un posicionamiento
fuerte por parte de vettel como decíamos
el deporte no es ajeno a esto no sé si
recuerdas raúl cuando comenzaron los
juegos olímpicos de invierno en beijing
el presidente putin fue el gran invitado
de xi jinping de 100 bien en esa gala y
jueves china acaba de confirmar que va a
comprar trigo a rusia de todas las
regiones de rusia nos explicaba jorge
que ucrania era precisamente uno de los
principales suministros de trigo para
rusia y china- en medio de este contexto
le garantiza a rusia comprarle todo su
trigo de todas las regiones previendo
con una interpretación prácticamente de
así ayudarle frente a las sanciones
económicas que va a vivir rusia el
deporte es algo que está casi que de la
mano con la política a veces cien por
ciento juan y es que lo que pasa en el
mundo en cualquier ámbito pues
obviamente nos tiene que importar no
podemos ser apáticos o lo que ocurra por
más lejos o cerca que sea lo que está
ocurriendo en el mundo pues ya estamos
en un mundo globalizado y todo lo que
ocurra en economía deportes decisiones
políticas pues nos termina afectando
juan muchísimas gracias entonces como
siempre por toda la información
deportiva pues en este caso no tan amena
pero también demostrando pues que todas
las decisiones políticas influyen en el
deporte porque al final deportes de
mente es política juego y al final que
los deportistas también tienen voces y
en ese celular pues tienen una con una
capacidad de hacerse ver enorme y puedan
hacerlo en ese momento tienen esa
capacidad para demos sus posturas para
el caso de es malo es muy llamativo
jugador clave en la selección rusia
haciendo un llamado de la paz es algo
muy llamativo reacciones de este tipo
que llegan desde sus cuentas propias de
personales con una gran difusión